patricia bouche de déchets un bonjour
bonjour merci nous avons rejoint au
château de versailles sur le parterre
nord pour parler de votre biographie
d'andré le nôtre qui est sorti il n'y a
pas très longtemps et fortes à propos
évidemment puisque on fête cette année
le quadri centenaire de la naissance
d'andré le nôtre voilà donc vous pour
ceux qui ne vous connaîtraient fin vous
êtes écrivain vous êtes biographe
surtout historienne et commissaire de
l'exposition qui a lieu actuellement le
nôtre en perspective voilà c'est ça
exactement elle raconté mois du 22
octobre et 22 février quatre mois voilà
donc on a encore le temps d'y aller oui
et on a même le temps d'y aller deux
fois parce que c'est une exposition qui
est assez extraordinaire et sur 1500
mètres carrés vous avez environ 400
objets
65 prêteurs ont contribué à cette
exposition et comme pour la première
fois on rassemble à la fois les chefs de
sa collection et les dessins les
terrains pour des problèmes de
conservation doivent tourner donc ceux
qui sont déjà venus peuvent revenir dans
deux mois puisque en sachant
qu'ils ont longtemps exactement dont
elle est sortie mais dynamique et furets
sont au personnage au sujet donc voilà
d'accord on vient et en relief qui est
extrêmement riche alors dites moi un
petit peu comment vous avez eu l'idée
d'écrire cette biographie parce qu'on
pourrait dire depuis 400 ans
tout a été dit et redit oui c'est
exagéré a l'impression en fait en fait
pendant les vous cacher en 2000 il ya
déjà eu des grandes manifestations à
l'occasion du tricentenaire de la mort
d'andré le nôtre à savoir robotique 1
septembre 1700 des colloques et une
grande exposition était prévu également
à cette époque là et moi je travaillais
sur un personnage qui s'appelle henri
dupuis jardinier de louis xiv illustre
inconnu et à 3 alors pourquoi sur lui en
fait c'est une commande béatrix saule ça
oui voilà qui directeur du musée de
versailles à l'époque conservateur
général avait souhaité développer une
collection sur les métiers de versailles
on parle alors side de frivolité et
c'est évident le roi exercer son métier
de roi et donc l'idée avait été de
commencer par un jardinier tout le monde
croit connaître ordre et le n'oserait
donc on s'est dit tiens il ya un nom qui
revient tout le temps dans les comptes
des bâtiments du roi et non complètement
passée aux oubliettes de l'histoire
c'est un certain henri dupuis qui arrive
en 1661 comme simple jardinier et qui
travaillait sous les ordres de le nôtre
et s'ils ont ce talent ou et surtout
surtout qui va terminer gerny enchaîne
de l'ensemble des jardins de versailles
et de trianon de l'orangerie c'est un
destin extraordinaire et je découvre à
l'occasion de toutes ces recherches
plein de chaussures andré le nôtre que
je croyais connu et donc résultat des
courses au moment de ce tricentenaire la
mort de lenôtre au contraire je me rends
compte à l'occasion du colloque si l'art
de le nôtre les travaux ont bien avancé
sur l'art de le no 1 il n'y avait pas de
véritable biographie et 2 les détails
qui étaient racontées était toujours des
détails attirer des mêmes sources
et contredisait un certain nombre de
deux aides objet la relever donc c'est
le la suite du monde en tête mais ce que
j'avais fait un travail d enquête voilà
et sur combien de temps vous dit au
total ça fait 15 ans dans quête comme
une enquête plus haut parce que c'est
celle là c'est quand on voit l'épaisseur
du livre non mais c'est 400 pages ben
oui enfin m oui un peu plus avec les
menottes écoutez il fallait au moins ça
comme un personnage qui a vécu 87 ans
était extrêmement violent pour l'époque
déjà oui c'est bien pour l'époque oui
dans sa famille où on vit longtemps
quand on survit on vit longtemps et
c'est surtout la famille qui a été en
activité jusqu'à sa mort donc c'est
surtout ça qui est absolument étonnant
c'est à dire quand on ne croit plus
jusqu'au bout finalement voilà alors
nous donne enfin pour moi par exemple
lenôtre jardinier mais finalement en
lisant cette biographie on apprend que
pas que jardiner justement il avait
plein de fonctions fatale en plein de
facettes et il exerçait différents
métiers finalement absolument alors
dites nous appeler quelqu'un qu'on
prenne à l'heure en fait déjà le
jardinier on imagine toujours le
jardinier avec un chapeau une bêche on
est beaucoup plus loin on est dans la
figure d'un jardinier du roi son grand
père était déjà jardinier du roi s'il y
avait plusieurs centaines de jardinier
non mais ça va plus loin que ça servait
en fait on est cerné sur d'autres
métiers siens qui avait plus dans paris
plusieurs centaines de jardinier il n'y
avait que moins d'une dizaine de
jardiniers du roi donc c'est déjà son
grand père était déjà un personnage qui
fait partie d'une élite au service des
rois son père non seulement est
jardinier du roi mais en plus ce
dessinateur défaire d'un miroir il y en
a que deux à l'époque donc comme andré
le nôtre n'est elle est déjà dans un
sérail prédestiné à dessiner des jardins
c'est un fils de quoi un fils de voilà
voilà ces familles avec un crayon on
peut cibler les bonnes clés à laon qui
vont avec voilà c'est pas gagné mais il
se trouve que tout à fait apparemment
donc en fait il est architecte
finalement et lorsqu'il faut ajouter en
plus de ces cas qu'une casquette qu'on
soupçonnait et c'est parce que la figure
du jardinier et paysagistes architectes
de jardin etc déjà été décrit par
d'autres dans des monographies ça c'est
soit ils veulent donc quand même
énormément de travaux là dessus en
revanche ce sur quoi n'avait jamais mis
l'accent ces sur sa fonction de
contrôleur général des bâtiments qui
explique tous en tant que contrôleur
général des bâtiments c'est que c'est un
office
du roi c'est un officier durant le
jardinier est déjà un officier du roi le
dessinateur et le également les
sénateurs mais ce sont ce qu'on appelle
des charges c'est moins honorifique que
celle de
contrôleurs à des bâtiments il puisait
conseiller du roi donc c'est quelque
chose de nori fiq et en même temps
quelque chose de réel puisque c'est lui
qui auprès de colbert puis de vous voir
donc
va mener la politique de louis xiv et
ils sont trois contrôleurs des bâtiments
une année sur trois une même fonction
exercée réellement au point que ça c'est
passionnant c'est que quand colbert
vamour va mourir louveau apprend sa
succession est bien le noter est encore
là et c'est à lui que l'on demande de de
faire la lumière sur des malversations
qui sont d'intervenir sur les chantiers
à l'heure qu'il n'était pas un exercice
ça prouve la pleine confiance à la fois
du roi et de l'ensemble de l'année mais
très gentiment sa probité sont d'accord
voilà ce qui donne la particularité de
le nôtre c'est qu'il était aussi
quelqu'un qui était un immense
collectionneur voilà c'est là je voulais
en venir donc c'était un grand amateur
d'art il a même passé commande je crois
plus sain pour un tableau particulier il
avait dans une collection de tableaux de
les bronzes des médailles mais alors
vous dites moderne ça veut dire
quoi à bescat parce que rien n'aurait pu
collectionner des médailles et antiques
lui la grande collection de médailles
contemporaine donc un certain nombre ont
été données par le roi toutes les
médailles à la gloire du roi gars soir
en or ou en argent mais la particularité
de l'onho il y avait une belle
collection de médailles qui était connue
1500 médaille en avait trois cents à la
gloire du principal ennemi de louis xiv
avant guillaume iii d'orange est par
ailleurs
il avait chez lui deux portraits de
guillaume iii de range ce qui montre à
la fois son indépendance d'esprit we
have eyes et pour être dérangeant mais
c'est surtout louis xiv le tolérait
l'accepter c'est sans doute ça l'amusé
parce que ça faisait des années qu'il a
osé couple sait faire ça oui et puis
vint il se promenait il y avait une
médaille dans sa pièce dans sa poche et
puis hop il en sortait lui les 10 euros
en voilà une qui est bien contre vous
alors oui le roi l'accepter donc c'est
savoir sur tout c'est proximité entre
les deux c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
les écueils nos relations assez unique
tous les deux ils ont eu ce qu'ils ont
l'air très proches on a l'impression que
lou 14 je fais une confiance totale il
le laisse partir en italie mans moto il
a hâte qu'il revienne
voilà ils n'ont pas là sans l'autre ils
ont elles à 35 ans quasiment pas pendant
tout pendant tout ce temps oui mais 60
ans parce que en fait quand louis xiv à
la mort de 8 13 ans nés en 1643 way
louis xiv à cinq ans le node à 30 ans
ils ont une génération d'avant donc le
nôtre a l'âge d'être le père de visage
et lui 14 a toujours connu le dos et ce
qui va ce qui fait partie des nouveautés
que le trouver c'est la finesse de la
conversation de lenôtre donc on a géré
trouver maints exemples de ces la
finesse de cette conversation on le voit
apparaître à la fois avec des
scientifiques comme ligue 1 sous loue un
déjeuner très tôt chez le bernin auprès
de deux figures ecclésiastiques qui vont
faisait partie des esprits les plus
brillants de leur temps très proche de
l'entourage de montespan connus pour
leur esprit
et gaulle hier l'arrêt vannes oui oui
très proche également de madame de
maintenon aussi vite ou le circle avant
le cercle des précieux et tout le cercle
des descentes effectué l des
mathématiciens des chercheurs autour
autour des couvent des minimes avec le
père mersenne moizer dont il avait un
esprit tout à fait à la hauteur capables
de motiver
curieux
intéressés par tout est alors c'était à
qui on pourrait le comparer à trabzon
c'était vraiment la coqueluche de son
temps tout le monde se l'arraché il
fallait avoir fait dessiner son jardin
par par le nôtre c'était alors j'aime
j'aime pas les comparaisons je vous dis
pas que ça sans façon réductrice et
elles ne sont pas forcément adaptées
surtout avec un saut de temps plus large
et puissance à vous donner le nom d'un
grand jardinier de notre temps de notre
taux je vais donner tout ce qu'ils vont
me dire et moi
mais en revanche et c'est surtout qu'on
n'a pas d'équivalent de d'un grand
concepteur de jardin qui soit également
au sein d'un ministère
équivalent de la culture l'industrie
les finances et sera chargée de
surveiller les comptes une année sur
trois et on n'a pas de fils et puis on
n'a pas de figure qui a été un aussi
grand collectionneur donnant au roi
seulement voilà il y les ou coupe par
dont il a fait don avant sa mort de la
collection rois et le roi des nuits
agitées
oui c'est si l'avancé via les jeunes
arrivent en disant de sa collection non
c'est ce qui était autant étonnant c'est
qu'il a donné une infime partie de sa
collection les billets les plus
prestigieux ce qu'on voit dans
l'exposition on voit une partie donc on
a poussin le lorrain etc mais s'il donne
au roi 3 pouces un nom en corse est chez
lui à choix qu'ils avaient tous donné
accès mon pare donc ce qui est
hallucinant c'est que à sa main quand on
entrera chez seller sa maison et bien qu
est-ce qu on découvre on en a encore
dans un salon octogone y avait encore 93
tableaux arrachés donc voilà aussi bien
des petits maîtres et les souvenirs de
rapporter de son voyage en italie que
des pièces encore prestigieuse accord
donc on le retrouve quelques unes de ses
pièces dans l'exposition oui de l'autre
entre la fois le don du roi voilà des
choses le roi a accepté et que le cobra
exactement vous avez bien lu mais voilà
c'est un honneur de donner orient à
essayer de vous expliquer d'ailleurs
très bien que si on accepte un tableau
après il faut refaire toute la côte où
l'accrochage parce que ça décale tous
enfin voilà il arrive après un tableau
voilà la réponse experts voilà donc on
lui fait de la place on lui fait la
place d un grand honneur c'est un grand
honneur et et puis et puis voilà normal
que tout ça ils avaient l'air de rester
complètement ya pas la grosse tête non
il a l'air assez sympathique a fallu
sida c'est oui vous vous êtes attaché
aux personnages ou wii est en fait jugé
comme daniel sais j'ai commencé à m'y
intéresser par par curiosité parce que
voilà à trié par cette figure que dont
on a dit tant de choses et finalement
sur le plan personnel on n'avait rien
ben voilà c'est ça qui nous manquer
c'est un peu de chair g voilà puis au
fur et à mesure je les trouvais très
sympathique - pour ses bons mots qui ont
été colportées que sa capacité de
résistance et ça c'est assez réjouissant
c'est à dire au coeur du pouvoir savoir
dire non savoir ne paraît
ces trois vallées son objectif oui
vraiment quelqu'un de bien extrêmement
égalé avec une optionnelle voilà une
belle à la réalise il mével histoire
beau personnage exactement est alors un
grand merci parce que grâce à bourrou
découplage chose donc je le courage tout
le monde à se plonger dans cette bible
mais la partie patricia merci verdict